[Music]
having been on YouTube for more than
half of a decade now I've gotten a lot
of comments a lot of questions in the
comments section and some of them fall
into certain classes many of them are
quite good and provokes some great
discussions some of them aren't quite up
to snuff and that's what I'm shooting
this new video series about it's sort of
FAQ not only for questions but also for
common issues that arise and the one
that I'm going to talk about here is
when somebody writes a comment on a
video and it's got no discernable
connection whatsoever to the topic of
the video and it's just coming out of
the proverbial left field so there's a
few things to say about that I mean the
first thing is of course it's it's nice
that people get excited enough to to
want to comment but we do want comments
to be more or less relevant to the video
because otherwise there's not a lot of
discussion involved in that and and I
have actually in the past quite not
quite often answered questions that that
are not really on topic but you know
life is short art is long and there's
not a lot of time for for doing that
sort of thing so you know it's important
that that people asking questions they
keep them relevant to the the video and
you know I've done so many videos over a
thousand at this point just in my main
channel that you know if you do a search
and you've got you know some some topic
brewing in the back of your head you
might actually find a video that's more
closely connected with that if there's a
thought that you're dying to to get out
there or a question that you're dying to
ask me the other thing that I would say
is that when it comes to questions that
I'm that I'm being asked that don't seem
to really have much
action to whatever topic is being
discussed in the video there's there's
usually one or two things that that are
going on and and could be better
addressed somewhere else I've already
mentioned that you might find a video
that actually connects with that so you
know if you're asking me about John Paul
Sartre and and freedom on an Aristotle
video and you haven't connected it to
the Aristotle video topic in some way
you can look at my cert videos and maybe
those are the places to actually ask the
question or if you watch the video you
might find your question answered
you know you might also find some more
questions popping up along the way
that's that's okay for philosophy the
other thing is you know I do in fact
have a channel you know there's a stream
just for the channel you can ask me
questions just within the channel and I
think a lot of the questions of these
you know sort of disconnected sorts are
better asked directly to me rather than
cluttering up the comments section of a
video one of the reasons why you would
want to do that other than the fact that
you know you're more likely to get a
response from me is that you know if you
think about what these these videos are
we have the video itself and then
there's all these comments beneath it
and you know if you read through them
sometimes quite a few of them are asking
great questions or making useful points
or making connections to two other
things and you know I want that to be
there as something like a resource for
the other people that are viewing the
videos I want them to be pretty relevant
you know I'm really happy this is a
little bit of a digression I'll come
back to the main topic in a moment I'm
really quite happy when I look at other
YouTube channels and the comment
sections on their videos that my comment
sections are
at the swamps that that really you know
if we use that metaphor that's
circulating around really need some
draining that that quite a few people's
comments sections are you know common
sections are notorious for having lots
of trolls and lots of people saying
terrible things I don't get quite so
much of that but I want to keep it you
know really focused and connected to the
video because other people you know
years from now students lifelong
learners might be using them as a
resource alright so back back to the
main topic you know if you've got some
sort of question or comment and you
really want to get me to to address it
like I said you don't want to go to the
comments section of a video that's
that's just not connected to it you
don't want to just find the latest video
that I've got and then you know plunk it
down there you want to go to the channel
stream and and leave the question or
comment there in in some cases it may be
something that requires a good bit of
discussion and if that's the case then
I'll probably suggest you you know book
me for a tutorial session in other cases
it might not might not take that if I
can answer it fairly quickly with the
resources that I that I have I usually
try to do so so you know this is a you
know a common thing that comes up and I
suppose the last thing that I would say
is if you see this this video appended
as a response to your comment or
question well there's there's a couple
things to keep in mind one is well it's
because you ask something that it may be
relevant but I don't see any possible
immediate connection to what it is that
was being discussed in the video so you
know if you think that I'm wrong about
that maybe you want to follow it up by
making the case or it could be that you
actually did ask something out of left
field because you're really interested
in that sort of thing and you didn't
realize that you were posting it on
that is about some totally different
topic in that case you know don't don't
feel too bad because you will be one of
at this point literally thousands to do
that sort of thing
I have had you know we're now in like
the you know the five digits for a
number of comments on my videos total
and quite a few of them have been in
that sort so you know don't don't take
it too badly and just find the right
place for getting the sorts of answers
that you want the last thing to say is
you know a lot of people ask questions
that I think they can probably answer on
their own by doing a fairly minimal web
search whether in YouTube or you know in
the larger internet and you know I
appreciate that people come to me as as
the the expert on these things but it
you know it's really important for one's
education that one learns what we call
information literacy that is where to
find these quality sources of
information so that you know the other
part of it is is becoming you know
moving yourself beyond the absolute
beginner stage into the intermediate
stage where you know something about the
things that you're asking about you know
you have a great idea about what sort of
questions you want to ask and follow up
on and where to go to get that
information I love seeing that sort of
thing
and so if you know one of these
questions becomes something like a
teachable moment and you're watching
this video you know and you say oh well
that's that's that's me that's what I
actually want for my viewers and
subscribers to get to the point where
they probably don't need to ask me a lot
of questions or you know if they do
they're all relevant because they're
already engaged in the process
themselves of figuring out where to find
the answers to the questions that
they've got
[Music]